For our experts in emotion interview.
We have the honor of speaking with doctor June Tangney,
um,
on shame and guilt,
the good,
the bad,
and the ugly.
So Dr Tangney received her phd in clinical psychology from the University of
California,
Los Angeles,
and is currently a professor of psychology at George Mason Mason University.
She's a fellow of the APA is division of personality and social psychology and
the American psychological society.
She's authored or edited several books on shame,
uh,
including and,
and as well as guilt and self conscious emotions.
These books include shame and guilt,
social psychological foundations of clinical psychology,
the self conscious emotions,
theory and research and the handbook of self and identity.
Her research has been funded by the end,
Ida and I see HD NSF and the John Templeton Foundation.
Um,
she's also a very much loved teacher and recipient of the George Mason
University's teaching excellence award.
So I now turn to our experts in emotion interview with doctor June Tangney.
Okay.
Oh,
welcome.
June.
Thanks for speaking with us today.
Thank you for happy.
It's always nice to speak to another June out there.
So I wondered if I could ask you to start off by telling us a little bit about
what first got you interested in the study of emotion.
Um,
hold on.
I've always been an emotional person and interested in emotions and,
um,
when I first started doing work in this area,
yes,
I'm almost 30 years ago,
I guess I'm [inaudible] we're not really you seen?
Yes.
Hm.
I do.
Yup.
For sure.
For both.
That Eh,
Eh,
was dissuaded by a number of people to bed.
I had become interested in the emotions of shame and guilt.
Having read Helen Block Lewis's buy canned.
Yes.
I was raised a Catholic and um,
really had some fundamental questions about how these emotions can be useful and
when they go awry.
Hmm.
So I mean,
since then you've really pioneered the field of research,
looking at a family of self conscious emotions.
And so I wanted to ask you a bit about your work here.
Um,
and in particular,
I mean,
like I said,
you know,
you're well known for your influential work in the family of self conscious
emotions and particularly looking at guilt and shame.
And I wanted to start off asking some broad questions,
which is sort of what do you consider to be the most important features of what
makes self conscious emotions a unique class in themselves?
What,
what are they in your perspective?
Well,
it's a really interesting set of emotion where,
um,
the target of evaluation is the fell and the evaluator themselves.
So the self is evaluating the self.
These are pretty advanced it emotions.
They don't appear within the first six months of life.
In fact,
people argue about when exactly they emerge,
but it's necessary to have a sense of self is separate from the world.
It's necessary to have a set of standards by which you evaluate it,
the self.
And in the case of guilt,
it's necessary to have the ability to make a distinction between oneself and
one's behave here.
So these are emotions that develop later in life.
Um,
certainly,
um,
shame may emerge around age three,
guilt,
maybe five or six or seven.
Um,
and,
um,
they're,
they're really complex social emotions that have a lot of implications for once
and interpersonal relationships and also emotions that have important
implications for how we feel about ourselves and how we behave in the future.
And so what do you see as some important sort of next steps or self conscious
emotions?
Oh,
there's so much yet still.
Um,
it's been exciting to see,
um,
Ma researchers doing work on the self conscious emotions,
and really broadening our,
our notions about what falls within that,
that families,
for example,
shame and guilt are really,
um,
kind of classic self conscious emotions.
But pride has been receiving a lot of the attention recently and,
um,
a little less so embarrassed.
Yeah.
So that's exciting to see,
but we still have so many questions left on an third for the next generations of
served jury.
Uh,
I think we'll keep question is,
um,
that we need to better understand the situations or the conditions under which
shame and guilt can be adaptive versus maladaptive.
I think a lot of the research is kind of
the adaptive
functions of guilt and the hidden costs of shame.
Um,
but I think understanding when Shane can be useful and adaptive is something
that we need to explore.
And also when guilt can be become problematic for people both as individuals and
in their relationship.
Um,
another big question for me is,
um,
when did Shane lead to anger and aggression versus withdrawal and depression?
We know that shame can take us down a number of different paths,
but it's not really clear for whom and under what conditions people respond to
threatening feelings of shame and these different ways.
I'm a big question that has
puzzled me for,
for,
for decades is where do individual differences in proneness to shame and
proneness to guilt come from?
We know that they're pretty well established by at least,
um,
middle elementary school.
Uh,
but we don't know much about how people develop these individuals.
It doesn't seem to cities simply a matter of shame,
prone honors have shame prone daughters or should feel prone fathers have built
on.
Um,
and it doesn't seem to be just a matter of temperament.
And so I think that's a really big mystery for us.
So,
I mean,
you're talking about guilt and shame a lot.
And I mean,
one part of your risk that's been so important is to,
you know,
systematically compare these two motions,
which I think a lot of people in their everyday life confuse them or use them
interchangeably.
And I wonder if you could say a little bit about what are the core features of
guilt and shame and what are their similarities,
but also what are the really important differences?
Right.
Well,
the similarities are they're both negative self conscious emotions that feel
pretty bad.
They occur when we fail or track progress in ways that are,
um,
important and meaningful to us in our environment.
Um,
but the differences when people feel shame,
they feel as a
person,
I'm a bad person for having done this.
Whereas when people feel guilt,
they feel bad about a specific behavior.
I feel bad for having done that.
And this differential emphasis on self versus behavior seems to give rise to
very different motivations and very different,
phenomenal,
logical,
uh,
kinds of experiences.
So when people feel shame about the self,
they often want to shrink into the floor.
And then disappear or they feel impaired or for the moment they feel defensive
often.
And,
uh,
really want to initially escape from the shame and do seem situation.
When people feel guilt about a specific behavior,
they're not so threatened about the cells and they're more able to focus on the
consequences of their behavior for other people.
So there was a press tours,
um,
confession,
apology in somehow repairing the harm that was done.
So I see guilt,
Jen has been a more future oriented kind of prosocial emotion,
whereas shame may sometimes have those,
those outcomes,
but often it'd be people down the path of defensiveness and sometimes anger and
aggression.
Interesting.
So I mean you've also looked at these divergent social consequences associated
with guilt and shame as well,
which you've alluded to.
And I wonder if you could say for example,
I mean your work has looked at ways in which they differentially relate to
empathy.
Um,
so how can guilt and shame be so distinct and the way they relate to how we
understand other people in their minds and their feelings?
I think one of the key differences is that is that shame is a very self focused
self.
This kind of emotion,
it's about me,
not about you and how I hurt your feelings.
It's about me being a bad person.
And so the focus is really on the self,
taken away from others in the field with guilt,
you're focusing on at behavior somewhat apart from the south.
And I think draws people's attention more the impact of that behavior on other
people.
And so it seem like this is a very
close link between feelings of guilt and feelings of empathy,
um,
whereas if anything,
shame seems to interfere with an empathic connection.
And we have data now from a study of about 500,
um,
felony offenders showing that progress to guilt,
uh,
negatively predicts Rhea fence and a rearrest where shame has a much more
complicated relationship with hope,
which released adjustment.
So for the most part,
um,
shame leads to external validation of blame,
which then leads to reascend.
Um,
but there's a direct effect which can be in inventory.
So what that says to me is that shame is a complex emotion,
which sometimes can be helpful in,
uh,
inhibiting Rhea fence,
but often leads us down a path of defensiveness and basically doing that,
learning from our mistakes and doing the same thing in a little break.
What about,
I mean,
that is so fascinating and I know you've also looked at differences between
guilt and shame and fostering different sort of motivational tendencies to help
redress maybe kind of more socially embedded problems.
Yes.
And,
um,
people who do work on,
group based shame and guilt,
that's another whole literature that is really been burgeoning in the past year.
So focused a lot on how group-based shame and guilt motivate people to,
um,
address social injustices that have been perpetrated perpetrated by their
groups.
Fantastic.
So having talked about kind of what first got you interested in motion and then
all the,
you know,
just amazing work you've done in the realm of self conscious emotions,
especially shame and guilt.
I wonder what you think from your perspectives in store for the future of
emotion given it as such a young field still.
Yes.
Um,
there's lots of additional areas to look at.
I think that the,
uh,
the work that people are now beginning to,
to do looking at neuro endocrine correlates of shame and guilt to really
interesting.
One of the challenges we have in studying these moral emotions is that they
don't have clear facial expressions associated with them.
In fact,
um,
uh,
guilt,
no postural or facial expressions associated with it.
I think that the guilt sign is,
I'm sorry,
you know,
are,
um,
and so I think I'm learning more about the brain and um,
uh,
how brain functions when we're experiencing these moral emotions and also how
people who are prone to shame versus prone to guilt,
um,
may differ in terms of their brains functioning is a really exciting area.
And that's the thing is we don't know much about how she dealt play out in
interpersonal context.
Even though they're very social emotions,
there's been almost no work done.
Um,
the phenomena of guilt tripping and tripping other people,
um,
when people do not,
what the outcomes are when this happens a lot in real life.
Um,
but social psychologists haven't really examined very closely and I think that's
an important direction.
Well,
I just wanted to ask you then to,
so when students come to you and they ask you questions about should I,
you know,
embarked in the study of emotion or what should I be thinking about if I do,
what kind of advice do you give sort of the future scholars,
you know,
in the field?
Yeah,
well I give them the advice my advisor gave me,
which is first of all,
if that's where your heart is,
go for it.
Yeah.
Um,
it's a really exciting field of research now.
and I think,
um,
the second piece is be the pay very close attention to measurement.
These are difficult emotions too to measure.
Sometimes people have difficulty even reporting accurately on feelings of shame
in the moment,
for example.
And I think one of our challenges in the field is to come up with better,
especially it measures about shame and guilt.
Absolutely.
So then I just wanted to say thank you so much Jan,
for speaking with us today.
It's been a delight.
Thank you very queasy.
And reading this wonderful series.
Okay,
so this concludes our experts and emotion interview with doctor June Tangney
from George Mason University.